Gary Vaynerchuk is back hot on the heels
of his last book crushing it the Thank
You economy is his latest book what's
going on Gary you know I'm just happy to
be back in the studio well that Mack the
studio cuz the Tron 3000 broke or
whatever happened but I'm happy to be
back on the show
you know it's widely considered that I
am the single greatest guest of your
program yes under 25 episodes in trends
so twisty yes and so you know I'm just
ready to win again I heard Moe Kaufman
wanted to be the guest of the year and I
decided 11 and I decided I'm not gonna
allow that to happen so I appreciate you
having me back on absolutely I love the
confidence early on in the game set the
tone set the tone and I I think Moe's
gonna be a little crushed oh he's gonna
be so devastated he'll be absolutely
we'd ever seen yes well let me say one
thing about the Jason nation that I know
yes that I do a lot of stuff a lot I'm
very lucky I do a lot of real TV a lot
of podcast so I'm doing I'm going to do
our people I'm willing to do it all
right we got five PR people you know 17
no I'm just kidding I mean you know if
you can pump out good content things
will happen right I will tell you that
this shows appearance a year and a half
ago is still a thing I get I see in my
Twitter stream I get emails about you
know there were plenty of people that
bought the Thank You economy Romi
letters like got the new book by the way
first found out about you on Jason's
show so chase you have a little bit of
an audience here yeah and a great
audience and they I think what they
connected with in that episode was you
were featured for 45 minutes an hour
hour and a half we just kept going and
going I don't think anybody ever each of
you do that what you see it's like
you're on surprise they're like oh yeah
dirt and we're a dirt we're out done
boom but it's a different thing when you
say I also said get off the [ __ ] train
which has taken on a life of its own I
really missed them a merchandise
opportunity there I think we could have
sold some serious t-shirts I somebody
made some really nice ones let me thank
our sponsor Trotta Trotta is a
crowdsource pay-per-click marketplace
making online advertising easy for
startups and entrepreneurs Trotta has
more than 1,000 paid search experts who
create the keywords in a copy for
advertisers using Trotta
you know about this because you've
bought sem before and it's a great
company I met when I was in Boulder
and if you're a paid search expert and
you want to use your skills on the you
know on the DL down low you can go visit
the Toronto website and work there maybe
even will night use the promotional code
twist and get five hundred get a $500
rebate if you spend three months in the
Toronto marketplace and meet their
minimum monthly budget requirements
whatever that is but thank you to at
RADA and everybody say thank you to at
RADA on twitter for making independent
media like this possible so it's been a
year the first book did tremendous New
York Times bestseller yep I just found
out this also is a New York Times best
seller Wow when I come out this came out
ten days ago ten days yeah and it's
gonna be number 200 New York Times
bestseller list I'm gonna kill that
[ __ ] Suzy Orman but you know that's how
that is you know if she saves people
money Oprah Oprah just pump the [ __ ] out
of her so you know I get Jason she gets
Oprah I only have so much of a shot yeah
that's true that's true so what's the
basic premise I mean you don't write
these things lightly I know you have
like an 18,000 book deal with somebody
this is a good chance to break the news
because I know enough people watch this
this is done with Harper business right
my last book deal my Tembo feel was
signed with Harper studio that dissolved
when the guy who created it left so this
was a separate book deal I actually have
no more books that I have to write ah I
wrote this 18 months after crush it I
don't expect to write another book for a
while mainly because I think you have to
work you know I don't wanna just pump
him out for the sake of pumping him out
right um no is him tomorrow I might wake
up and you know maybe I'll come up with
some amazing idea tonight and want to
but I kind of feel like I need a little
bit of a break this book feels really
good to me I feel like I've matured
dramatically since I wrote crush it I
start a company with my brother AJ
called vaynermedia right so we've done a
lot of consulting in corporate America
for you know PepsiCo and Green Mountain
coffee and Campbell's and the NHL big
companies I understand the entrepreneur
thing I understand the small business
thing but I've learned a lot about
corporate this talks about what is
really the ROI of giving a crap like is
the world really changing like it is my
firm belief that the world is changing
it is my firm belief that if you have to
care about the end user in a world that
we all know we live in which is based on
word of mouth
and social equity and and so I dig into
this pretty deeply and it's really funny
I actually came up with the title this
book giving an interview about crush it
crush it they wanna crush it was doing
extremely well everybody was stunned it
did well you know all the other social
media books in 2008 did not do well
right mine sold extremely well mainly
cuz you bought a crapload of copies so I
appreciate yes um
and I I in one interview said they
finally they were pushing they were kind
of is like a Washington Post you okay
house okay
um I they were like pushing they're like
come on why do your book sell and I was
trying to figure out and after the
interview they told me they thought I
bought all my copies right they dug into
it they try to like expose me I didn't
know what was going on they were pushing
they're like why'd your book do so well
and finally said well the Thank You
economy and it stuck I think that I paid
forward so much for my community at the
time 800 episodes of Wine Library TV you
know how much at replying I do on
Twitter answered my email you know give
give give give give that when I came and
I asked for something and it was only 20
bucks it was an easy ask it was an easy
ask I almost call this book guilt
marketing right it's almost it's it's
sort of like Evernote where people feel
so good about the product the the CEO
troubles on the show they just pay and
the number one reason they give is
because they want to support the product
it's like how I feel about you I walked
in here and just gave you a hundred
bucks absolutely so the the the concept
that social media is changing everything
let's unpack that a little bit the word
social media is broken right because the
word media is screwing with everybody's
head everybody thinks that's push right
medias been the same way for a hundred
years
print radio push right television push
you know banner ads push billboards push
email services push push push push push
push we are in the business of creating
content and we push the living crap out
of it right we are now living through
the first place where it's pull it's the
difference between what we're doing
right now which is creating and pushing
content compared to that skillset of
working the room after we're done I'm
gonna go over there and hang out with
these awesome people that decided to
come and hang and the skill set to work
the room and meet people and shake their
hands
is the skillset that I think businesses
need whether you're Ford or Apple or
Pepsi social context is gonna matter
everybody in our world says content is
king in my opinion of content is king
context is God right and the word
context is about to explode in mattering
to this room to the viewers to this
universe and so it's why you build the
product it's how you behave with your
customers even if you have millions of
customers like Apple you see Steve Jobs
writing these 1 a.m. emails and the guys
I matter busy he's got but he can't help
himself and he was a recluse he was he
would never respond publicly and then
something happened in the last two or
three years where even Steve Jobs would
write to people the blunt
honest I've never you saw that email
where he said what have you contributed
to the world why are you being so nasty
criticizing my products and it was like
wow Steve Jobs is actually engaging
listen customers I think I think first
and foremost especially people in our
space and we all know so much I mean
anybody that's even watching this show
is so far ahead
I'd love for them to wrap their head
around that the fact you're watching
this show means that you clearly do know
where the world's going at some level in
a way that so many other people don't
I do believe our space is ridiculously
cynical I'm shocked how cynical our
society is in general you know as a guy
who's got good guy DNA and has an
amazing mother and raised him well you
know I'm shocked how many people just
don't believe you can be good by the way
I'm not good because I'm such a great
guy I'm good because I firmly believe
that that's how you're gonna have to do
business I'm here to sell stuff I'm here
to make business happen I want to buy
the New York Jets I'm not mother Teresa
I have no interest in rock climbing and
drinking tea and all kumbaya and I want
to build businesses I think being good
is going to be a substantial backbone of
that what's that drinking tea and going
rock climbing a dig at Kevin absolutely
not my best friends of course of course
and it's a big at San Francisco in
general and I don't really mean it I
love SF but there is this thing that I
just want to make sure listen I'm a
little bit disgusted with myself Jase I
talk a lot about huggy feeling like it
shocks me that I am this person at 35
you know because I'm the kid that ripped
up flowers rang
I'm sold it back I'm raw right I now you
realising being the nice guy and the
thank you is what's gonna get you to the
next level well here's the thing right I
owe I grew up in a family business we
lived on the Thank You economy I lived
to deliver a case of wine to somebody if
they had a bad experience or took care
of them but what happened it's like this
if somebody tripped in your parking lot
as you went out to your beautifully
colored mobile tonight yeah and a lady
trips and you help her up and we all
laughed right how many people in the
world know that you're a good guy to you
and her right if so many trips at the
Macy's Day Parade and you save her and
you pick her up before Snoopy crushes
her ass you're a national hero right
in my opinion what's happened to
business because of the transparency and
the ecosystem of the Twitter's and the
Facebook's and now the tumblers and
Korra's and on and on on in the world so
much of what we do in business is played
out in public and the return on
investment to being a good guy and a
good company has dramatically more value
it's just the way it is now listen and
let me say it here right now because I
know where you're going everything I
write about in this book and everything
I believe in the way I'm executing my
business is whether it's vaynermedia of
Wine Library or my personal brand is
gonna get ruined in five years why
because it's gonna be like email do you
more the first time you got email yeah I
was important it was pumped you're like
holy [ __ ] I'm not paying for a stamped
fee on this this is incredible no phone
call for you you couldn't you you got
mail and you would like start dancing
like santa came over right right no no
now what do you guys feel about email
you hate it right so when you say people
gonna be so nice we can be so good to
their customers even the airlines are
gonna treat us with respect and love and
I don't know where this I don't know
that it's gonna be come on attack here's
my here's my concern that companies are
gonna do it as a tactic right it comes
natural to me to engage right you know
the reason I did well on Twitter is I
was interested in summize more than I
was interested in Twitter right I
searched and I gave feedback I always
think of business is best when it's a
service above what they're actually
doing right my concern is that as
companies figure out what I'm talking
about here and realized people really do
win when they start engaging and caring
and answer
not putting their head in the sand right
in Korean context I think it's gonna
become a commodity I do I think it's
gonna become free shipping in 1998 when
I did pre shipping at winelibrary.com
it was one of the big its listen to this
we were a four million dollar business
at the time we're a 60 million dollar
business now it was the biggest day of
business we've ever had still to this
day okay free shipping was the first
time I ever did it 98 people were buying
wine that day like it had to cure inside
they were going nuts
one guy bought 20 cases left them note
and said I'm buying this wine for my
daughter's wedding
I called him living in the Thank You
economy back then not realizing it right
right I called him to thank him I said
hey Jim thanks so much I mean it's
incredible you know you know when's your
daughter's wedding maybe you know maybe
we can send some champagne or something
he goes oh no no no Gary
my daughter is 12 I guess of what he
goes oh she's 12 but this is such a sick
deal I got it I'm gonna put this in a
cellar and it's amazing now
everybody who's watching this is so
entitled so primed out right that they
won't even buy anything unless they have
free shipping and so what I'm saying is
that we don't realize how quickly we
become cultured to good stuff as
companies start getting nice to us where
wait do you think we're you want to know
where I really think this goes yes I do
I think you Jason wakes up in 40 years
tweets out I'm taking a run because now
you're a little bit older and you want
to lose 15 pounds okay I do okay so now
you're like I'm taking a run I believe
that the next day at your home is six
different pairs of sneakers for
headbands and a wristband and maybe an
iPad a little mini Lynott Apple they'll
never go there but here's the bottom
line you will have stuff every person
sitting here and every person watching
this right now in 12 years will be sick
of free ship being sent to them mark it
down I actually am a little sick of that
right now I have to be honest when
you're a superstar no but it is and you
want pink shirts who doesn't on the
picture I mean the pink shirt is just
tremendous I think any other respect and
it's a little respect
and by the way I got the the Tesla is
call it after why do you think I did it
that color it is happening already
though brands have figured out with some
of these tools what's the one Tyler that
does your score clout
out like this Klout score yeah they seem
to have figured out who the influence
was over this Klout score and I thought
it was a really dumb idea when I first
heard it yeah and now I think it's
brilliant it's brilliant because the you
know now understanding corporate they
don't want to really do the homework no
it's so much more fun to look at client
be like I'm great an 84 send them some
[ __ ] exactly and so now I'm a 73 or a 76
or something and they keep sending stuff
and they're doing movie tickets and it's
this and then Ford's agency is calling
me every day to try to get me to take a
survey I don't think a survey right so
you're right it's already and it's
that's the future it's gonna get
annoying these brands are gonna want to
do too much here's why and here's why I
want everybody understand I'm not here
to rob Ryan and this is why it's gonna
happen here's why I think it's gonna
happen I don't think people understand
how much a brand is willing to spend to
get to you guys they're willing to spend
an ungodly amount of money to get to you
now where are they spending it they're
spending it to through platforms that
keep a big chunk of change right now
these traditional plant networks
efficient not efficient nielsen CEO in
this book I write about the Nielsen CEO
came out and said well our numbers are
probably about 8 percent off if the
field Nielsen's is willing to come out
and say it's a percent off first of all
what's the real number 25 right second
of all holy crap imagine in our world
coming out imagine us coming out and
saying well we're billing you a percent
offer an hour traffic as a percent offer
this I mean yeah it's ludicrous and it's
on billions of dollars and here's the
other thing though it's 2011 like
billboards really do I really need to be
paying 1995 prices for billboards you're
telling me that the people in this room
people watching are actually looking at
billboards I don't know about you Jason
I'm scared shitless to drive look at
your fellow drivers they're not looking
at billboards they're not looking at the
[ __ ] Road yes they're bisecting yeah
so I mean so I need to be paying 1994
and really I need to be paying 1998 TV
commercial pray how many people in this
current little crowd here DVR shows
raise your hand and how many of you
isn't and how many of you fast forward
the commercials how many people well how
many people don't fast-forward the
commercials nice supportive oh yeah well
this guy what about the advertisement
actually technically Jason that is not a
great idea you know we have a lot of
sponsors we are very important to this
show
if there's a way I mean seriously though
look at that you saw it right and I'm
sure people at home hopefully you raise
your hand it's fun I mean I I mean why
are we paying prices in a reality that
is no more and so what companies are
starting why buy because it's all
service insertion no it's a circle jerk
people want to make it easy brand
managers of these big companies want to
just buy TV because they want to sit at
home and see the commercial that they
paid for and be like eh I made a
commercial they want to see the
billboard do you know that they put
billboards by executives homes
do you know billboard companies run
billboards by executives homes so the
CEO and the CEO oh when they drive on
the way to work be like there's my
billboard am I good I mean it's such a
how the fu billboard by the way the
whole Groupon LivingSocial battles so
fun they need to go into a steel cage
raw I love it but awesome she said
here's the bottom line it's all a system
right I mean it's a system that makes
sense that's the way they've always done
it it's easy here's what you do with
your hard on me if you want to be a CMO
at a major CPG company you play it safe
could you run a it's good correct you
run up you run a commercial right if it
does well you're a champion if it
doesn't you spend the next year
analyzing why it didn't do well I mean
it's really quite ludicrous it's super
non entrepreneurial and it's living in a
time that doesn't exist anymore so
what's gonna happen is younger blood is
coming in disruption is happening people
are getting put out of business see a
blockbuster see your boarders it's gonna
continue and what's gonna happen is
people gonna start looking at their
business and then I say wait a minute if
we want to get to the end user and we're
paying on average two hundred eighty
seven dollars and the data's not right
why don't we just give the two hundred
eighty seven dollars to Jason cuz he
just said that he's a runner
[ __ ] it let's give him three pairs of
sneakers and then maybe he'll buy the
fourth or fifth and six and you're
creating context right and Edison do I
think it's I hope people don't
misunderstood this is just on product
giveaway right let me give you an
example the Thank You economy at Wine
Library we had a customer who just
dropped 20 G's on wine very short and
from from Chicago I told Kristin at Wine
Library I want you to know
who this person is we found him on
Twitter we put him into our CRM system
we started following him we noticed that
he started tweeting about Jay Cutler
consistently I love you Jay Cutler don't
be mad at Jay Cutler if Jay Cutler
really didn't get hurt we would have won
we would him in a Super Bowl
marry me Jacob this guy loves Jay Cutler
I call Kristin I'm like Kristin I want
you to go to ebay I want you to buy a
Jay Cutler Jersey and I want you to set
him note saying thank you for becoming a
Wine Library customer that was huge for
him he told us that he's not shopping
with any other wine shop because we hit
his emotional center we didn't give him
free shipping to Wine Library we didn't
give him a wine rack or free glasses in
the context of our world we went all the
way left field and we touched the
emotional center if a company sent
something nice to your for your children
for your daughter right oh yeah that hit
you they caught you they got me skip hop
did that and that's it
they sent me tool boxes every single
product and they sent two of each I came
home to my wife yep I'm the greatest guy
ever yeah the skip hop diaper you have
the skip hop stuff I have my wife isn't
Fokin he's the CEO of me how old is your
daughter
twenty-one months 15 months yeah I mean
how is that change I was an entrepreneur
we could have that discussion - yeah I
mean it's it's the biggest shift in my
life I mean you know family is what you
live for I mean it's interesting you
know I'm gonna go politically incorrect
on you because that's you know I'm on
the first nine months I was like oh man
I'm a piece of [ __ ] I'm a bad guy like
why am I not like changing my life as
soon as she started interacting things
changed I think I don't know if that's a
dude thing I heard that yeah you know
once she started saying like when she
rolled into my room a couple of months
ago after we hung out all day Sunday
which is how my life's changed right the
reason I don't answer every email
anymore is because I used to sit on my
ass on a Sunday on a beautiful Sunday
afternoon and answer 900 mails would be
proud of myself that I caught up spend a
little time with Lizzy cuz she could
stay up later and we go now I spend that
time with Misha we spent a whole
hardcore Sunday together was ton of fun
Lizzy went out and did some stuff the
next morning I'm getting ready for work
she runs into my room she looks me dead
in the face and she's talking early very
early yeah which I'm not sure where
she's getting that from but I have an
idea she looks at me and she goes daddy
I'm back and that was it and I was like
and I was like like the way she
delivered it and I'm like wow now I
understand why I'm not going to work as
hard do as many things I need to be
around this kind of stuff so it's a love
that
is difficult to understand yeah and it's
uh it's the greatest thing that's ever
happened to me well let's go let me say
a couple more things about t ye yeah you
don't mind absolutely because because
I'm very concerned you have a very
educated viewership absolutely and I
want them to understand what I'm
obsessed with is I truly believe that
context matters so darn much I think it
matters I think it matters when you know
your community right I think it matters
when you care about them like I look at
this small crowd and I've talked to some
of them today on Twitter like or
yesterday it matters I know who they are
I hate this concept of we become less
you know like yet earnest from all the
old-school peeps like Oh society so
screwed up now you don't communicate
with each other you're out of your mind
you're not using the product I'm
communicating more than ever I have
context on much of this crowd
that I never could have without the
Twitter's and the Facebook's and
tumblers of the world right and so I'm
blown away by people's lack of
understanding that if somebody says your
products awesome and you wink at them
that acknowledgement means something
think about this think about when
somebody's giving you a head nod what's
a head nod it's such a half-assed thing
right like a head nod is not like some
unblocking about [ __ ] hugging I'm
talking about a head nod I'm talking
about you're walking in the office you
know you're kind of like a czar in this
establishment I'm sure that you know
these guys are working their ass off 19
hours and you walk by and you give them
a little head nod that [ __ ] that's huge
they're Punk Jason [ __ ] acknowledged
by me you know a head nod I had not it
matters a wink an lol a thank you these
things that you're doing in the trenches
matter the radio business has a billion
dollar business based on Drivetime radio
that mom is driving to the supermarket
and if you rock run a tide or a dub
commercial during drive time when she
goes into the supermarket she's gonna
buy your product right that's that's the
thesis of concept that's the concept and
I believe in the impressions I mean I do
believe in that I believe in branding
here's my thing though so what happens
when you actually do something nice in
the trenches for example Harrah's Casino
Group client of ours during CES we
monitored every conversation for 24
hours I heard west coast said
so my guys people stayed up for three
o'clock in the morning at Bainer you
know it's hardcore like in here yeah
dungeon style right right entrepreneur
so down so in the room somebody tweets
out during CES does anybody know where I
can see the Junior Olympic hockey game
one of my guys sees it call Caesars
Casino stores book says do you have this
they said yes they said can you reserve
a table for this guy yes they tweeted
him he goes he has a good time the next
morning we see this tweet from this
customer checking out of the Wynn
checking into Caesars that is ROI
awesome and so I'm just stunned at
people and by the way we are gonna be
living through the great bubble of
social media in the next three years
people gonna lose their shirts it's
gonna be a bubble and people gonna be
down on social media in next 36 months
because there's a lot of hype there's
clowns like me running around screaming
this is the best [ __ ] ever so it's gonna
it's gonna go through a bubble pop it's
gonna be a 99 to 2000 one thing the
internet was hot as [ __ ] right then 99
to 2001 the stock market collapsed right
because there was a lot of things done
wrong 95% of the stuff that I see on
social today is done wrong because it's
push it has no emotion it is no good
intent and everybody's treating it like
it's a traditional media platform which
it's not everybody's trying to give a
presentation during a cocktail party
okay so everybody's struggling with it
people are gonna struggle they're gonna
spend a lot of money and nothing good is
gonna happen
and this reminds me so much of 99 to
2001 this remind and people gonna make
decisions like the here's my favorite
blockbuster a bunch of 80 year old white
dudes sat in a boardroom and said hey
dick do you know this uh Netflix thing
no hey Johnny you see this thing no Paul
no anybody even hear of this Netflix
thing no [ __ ] it eight years later
you're out of business blockbuster right
and so innovation matters if innovation
didn't matter if social change didn't
matter
IBM would be dominating our world right
or Microsoft Microsoft would have never
let Google happened Google would have
never left Facebook happen
Facebook would have never let Twitter
happen and on and on and on and so I'm
just very concerned that people think
that their demo is not in social I hate
that mic well Gary my customers aren't
in social they're older everybody's
[ __ ] grandma is on Facebook
absolutely I mean come on that ship has
sailed like please don't give me boy
[ __ ] excuses cuz you don't want to put
in the work and that is what it is about
right I mean you go to Anna's companies
and they know they're supposed to be
doing it but yeah well they're just like
I am know these things what's the ROI
what's the RO they want a quantified I
always say well what the [ __ ] is the ROI
of your mother like I don't know what
the are I don't have beta to show you
the ROI of
Tamara Vaynerchuk but I can sit firmly
here and tell you that it's everything
it's the whole [ __ ] game because
without the way my mom raised me I'd be
a clown and so I don't understand how
people don't understand the emotional
app impact of business it's not just
black and white plus by the way
traditional your black and white data
sucks it's horseshit Arbitron the major
[ __ ] radio company and the bottom of
their website says the data from
Arbitron is the opinion of Arbitron it's
not even data it's not even [ __ ] data
do you know that nuisance sends little
questionnaires to people that have the
box and ask them to fill out the shows
they watch right you guys know that I
mean they're lying they're making it up
yeah I think I watched I watched PBS I
was watching Nova and then Meet the
Press the whole thing is really
interesting it's a whole circle jerk
right and it's gonna collapse
disruptions coming and the companies
that out care and actually keep when did
not caring about your end user become
not a real job or something didn't have
ROI yeah it's all going small town rules
Jason every your grandparents our
collective grandparents are much more
positioned to be successful in 2015 than
we are because we're entitled we're soft
we want everything to be scalable
everybody in our world that's super
smart wants everything to be scalable
and scripts and data and all this yeah
everybody in traditional right they just
want you know they want it to be the way
they want it and old school and and I
think it's something very much in the
middle it needs to be about human
interaction and you can scale caring
with social and it's interesting you
mentioned scaling because GoToWebinar
it's a pretty good segue was it him
that's amazing
go ahead your thing yep so thank you to
go to webinar for it's so awkward to do
a commercial in the middle of the social
thing but I actually use
gotowebinar to have 70 people on the
phone for the launch conference for all
the exhibitors I said everybody get on
the phone all the companies and we'll do
a Q&A session it worked brilliantly and
this is actually I think the future of
media I get to pick who's the sponsor of
the show and I only pick the products
that I actually use sure like
GoToWebinar 30 days free use the
promotion code twist it's like three
easy steps it works it's like
GoToMeeting but you can use like a
thousand people on it and I really do
appreciate them I always say thank you
to them you guys say thank you to on
Twitter just say thank you at
GoToWebinar for sponsoring this we can
start ups and that little thank you let
me tell you something I started doing
that on this week in tech I don't know
two years ago with leav and I said hey
you know everybody who's listening go
thank go daddy and go thank shorter
space and thank these guys and the
sponsors were more interested in the
thank-yous on Twitter or equally
interested as they were for the ad on
the show but let's understand why people
who are watching this right now would go
and do that you've clearly given them
enough that they feel like they want to
you paid forward
you didn't come at a left field you put
out a lot of content that doesn't cost
them anything yep right you've been in
the scene a long time so it's not only
skill set but it's actually engagement
in the audience and everybody's got
different levels listen Jason you you
know this better than anybody because
you were around the first day I started
the first day I did Wine Library TV when
I have zero brand equity in tech right
you know you were there so you watched
what happened with me sure there's a
million people that have come and gone
the reason I've been relevant is because
I'm just given as much a spot this is a
case study of my life and you haven't
stopped I mean I think that's something
that people forget you had done it
consistently for years now I mean how
many of these episodes have you done now
so I retired from Wine Library TV at
South by during my keynote I stopped at
episode 1000 right because I wanted to
continue to innovate I launched
something called daily grape I this is
the new eyeful this is the new iPhone
app and and it's still on the site too
and the androids coming but I feel like
I was meeting with a lot of startups I
do a lot of angel investing we've
invested some things together and I keep
yelling at them right they come in
they're like okay Gary here's what we
are we're like Cora meets Instagram with
a little gowalla and animation
the shade of path and I'm like I don't
give a [ __ ] you know like they go and
they're like and we're gonna be on
TechCrunch and we're gonna be you know
and Mashable's gonna write about us and
Chris Sacca and McClure investing in us
and I was like what does any of this
mean social proof you know what I mean I
was like what what problem are you
solving and do you give a [ __ ] about
your customer then all of a sudden I
kept saying well problem you solving one
day I'm driving and I'm taping while I'm
eating I'm like what problem by solving
with this I'm like entertainment has
value I get it there's a lot of content
out there so what I realize is wine
scares people right people watch my show
because nobody knows anything about wine
it's hard it's difficult there's a lot
everybody in wines a douchebag and so I
decided that a lot of bags there's a lot
of bags so now when you watch a show
mobili or on the site you can add a wine
to your wish list it goes into the app
right and now people are walking around
with their wish list so you're watching
the show you're like oh that sounds good
you hit one button it's on your phone
and now you know you go on a date you
want that cool you know you want to know
something or if you're just shopping and
you're into wine I just made my content
useful I think useful entertainment is a
very interesting evolution to where
things are going you know you made a
very nice compliment to me because I
know you've been pivoting heavily into
video you said I got to give you credit
you were on the video thing early very
early I I think that I'm evolving into
something that's gonna really matter
it's useful content it's actually
getting into people's the flow of their
daily lives solving some problem mobiles
the game right I mean medals the game so
that's that I Bana which I know did s
present at launch and they design so
product so I'm happy with that
it's interesting a lot of people been
stunned what a non-native app can look
like with cabana so that's been a fun
study but most of all it's shorter you
know my show was like 35 minutes and I
know I'm fond and all but you know it's
a lot of good news Austin it's
exhausting so now it's 7 5 6
all right snackable you know while
you're in the car texting instead of
watching you know the road instead of
looking at a [ __ ] billboard you can
watch daily grape nom and you know and
and it's just much more useful I mean I
already I'm only six episodes in
yesterday I get an email from a guy
watched a Riesling episode added to the
wish list went to a restaurant me and my
girlfriend said do you have this the guy
said not exactly that but close and we
loved it because it tasted like you
described
that's me scratching my happy it should
like okay good I'm executing on the
thesis if I enjoy dessert wine and pour
it more than I enjoy regular wine does
that make me like girly got I like the
sweet ones that make me like less of a
man like no listen I mean listen right
what's like a man's wine to drink it's
not like a dessert well I'm a huge fan
of this are like the ports I love that
stop this clearly you're not worried
about that look at the shirt you're
wearing right okay we know I run a break
all the time so you're not worried about
being girly you know who you are
you don't but I love that you're
Brooklyn absolutely by the way can we
talk about the mix I'm yeah [ __ ]
pissed what you don't like the Train no
I love the trade but I'd like to make
the playoffs I mean what you have to
give yourself I know I we need a big man
we need people gonna be a problem notice
what happens we didn't make the trade
we'd be one or two again like I agree it
was a great rate we're one or two games
below five me you bet Wilson got into a
big Twitter disguise I would I think we
were on the same page I'd like to trade
boy here's the thing you should drink
Manuel you should go tribe annual annual
be am
Yul s Yul s uh it is a late harvest
Grenache it is in my opinion better than
port though I love Portugal it's a
fourth of the price fourth of the price
I know you like that will do and it's
just tremendous wine and it's nerdy
geeky and I highly recommend ban you
will for you alright there you have it
you guys have any questions there in the
audience I see everybody's listening to
you be scared don't be scared and you
stirred my hollow staff can have a
question it's allowed to tell or do
something Tyler oh joy no choice
ah the very good question so the
question is Jesus Christ choice so the
question is if it's the Thank You
economy why not give away the book for
free the Thank You economy isn't called
the free economy you know so that's the
first reason and by the way and I said
it early on in this and it's super
important for me to context this I'm a
businessman right like I'm excited that
I put out real hardcore you know I like
that I'm a businessman that built like
Tony Hsieh Jason freed I like to buy
these books or support them because
they've gone out and actually built
businesses and I'm nothing against
Malcolm Gladwell and other people like
that but I really do enjoy the thought
of like buying business books from
people that have gone in and executed in
the trenches instead of people that have
taught at universities right I mean I
think that's interesting
um for me I'm a businessman I feel like
it's a super value for 13 or 14 bucks
for what I'm doing in there
and thank you economy the word thank you
represents I almost call this manners
marketing it just talks about a tact of
how to handle yourself in a transparent
word-of-mouth cocktail party business
world it doesn't talk about I wasn't
there a book like that free didn't
somebody do that yeah yeah
this isn't about free content at all
this has nothing to do with that that
would be a big reason why I wouldn't
give it away for free it just talks
about holy crap you kind of got to
become better and you've got to more
importantly then be nice it's create
context I think I'm just obsessed with
that word I'm fascinated by watching it
you know the fact that I can look
through the crowd and see Wanda because
we engage on Twitter and I don't really
know what you know I don't bite
old-school Sanders I don't really know
her but I can tell you right now the way
I feel about her by seeing her through
the crowd is definitely different than
somebody I've never met before and it's
been based on the social engagement
we've had on these platforms tonight
we're gonna hang a little bit longer
I've got a ton of stuff in the morning
I'm going back to my hotel room
hopefully pretty quickly I'm gonna lay
in my bed I'm gonna continue to engage
with my community because I think that
scales for me
more importantly me and Lady Gaga and
the beams we don't scale we're people
right companies do night and campbell's
and Ford have no excuse they can hire
their asses off to find people that will
go in there and vet tell their story
their brand story and actually give a
crap answer questions what what are
these with job title is is a prominent
there's no job time with these big
companies for them no you don't make it
there's no Nielsen's report saying that
based of hours worth of dollar 47 right
Thank You Todd I mean you know say it
again I mean I think you know hallelujah
it's coming it's by the way it's coming
clay and cloud has started the process
Nielsen's will buy clout it'll be cloud
Nielsen's and everybody's gonna in
corporate america is gonna be like okay
great now we could now is that maybe
like the low cloud score though these
are thing the people with a low cloud
left the funny part i want that i
actually think that's where the action
is
ah because if you're if you're Jason you
don't get you're used to getting tons of
free [ __ ] yet I mean any to me right
pammi Thompson in Arkansas if she gets
some free Doritos she's [ __ ] her
pants that's true the mommy everybody's
business plan has mommy blog no no
that's all I'm gonna get the mommy
bloggers all right that would be at our
- yeah let's do that for next year yes
that's a whole racket those mommy
bothers shaking people down ma if your
mommy blogger you better start policing
the other mommy bloggers because they
slam the people down the mommy blogger
thing is like you're right it's like goo
stuff it's like [ __ ] Tony Soprano out
there Dave they're gonna get their free
[ __ ] it's one way or the other but it's
gonna diluted the whole thing I mean the
whole thing I'm talking to these brands
they're so going off of that because
they're just they're taking everything
the hoarding everything and more
importantly mommy bloggers when you take
[ __ ] you better be transparent when
you're writing about it because your
communities gonna find out you're gonna
get exposed and you're not gonna have a
community what do you think this company
my likes did you see that
in there they came out without they you
do a tweet and it's an ad it's sort of
like what what's it what's e company
hearings badly there's a what do you
think that it has that fit into all this
I never listened as somebody who has
close to a million followers I've had
all the offers it's kind of hard to walk
away from like 30 G's for a tweet or 5
G's from a tweet right I mean it's not
so so easy do it for
you know I chair DS a whole nother
clutch I talked about it this by the way
and this is something a massively
passionate about welcomes calling
something naturally Kevin maybe he's so
maybe maybe you heard the rock climbing
thing I think that uh I think that image
if you tweet out if you tweet out how
are you doing hold it a second I'm
putting you live on the average Gary all
day hold on saying Kevin say he'll say
hello everybody say hello all right if
you tweet out that if you follow if I
get a hundred followers I'm gonna donate
$100 to Japan you're a [ __ ] face and so
can please everybody in the Twitter
world the Jason nation you guys are
passionate you guys are loud as [ __ ]
please do me a favor the next time
somebody tweets out if I get fifty more
followers will donate 50 bucks to the
Japan relief or you know 100 bucks to
New Zealand earthquakes foundation or
the Red Cross the next time you see it
please personally email me at Gary at
vaynermedia comm with the link so I can
piss on those people I hate that yes
hundred dollars [ __ ] yes it's so I
mean so like you know I feel like that
all bleeds into the same stuff every
person in this room and definitely every
person watching right now their [ __ ]
radars are phenomenal we know what's
going on we know that you just want a
hundred more followers that you know we
know we're not that stupid I'm just I'm
sickened by be player marketers thinking
they're so smart
it's just tactics and it's short sight
and it's hooking up instead of marrying
I want my companies to get their
customers to put a ring on it not to
just hook up for tonight mmm I like it
and I don't say a little stuff okay yeah
good Josh Josh get in here yeah what's
your advice to people have a personal
brand like a celebrity or something and
they are have too many followers to
really engage
Shh hmm personally I don't believe that
so like so here's my thing and I don't
know if you guys could hear on on the
could they catch it on the video they're
not repeat the question is what if your
celebrity or personal brand you have too
many followers to engage one-on-one
right
I don't here's my two thoughts first of
all I think effort is grossly
underestimated effort is something that
I don't think we're putting enough ships
on because as somebody who literally
tried to engage with every single
engagement as things started happening
in my life I remember last year in
January my sister had a baby it's a big
deal
super exciting comes kind of off the
grid for two or three days and a couple
tweets popped up saying Gary Vee you
changed you know you used to respond to
every one of my tweets you even respond
to my last two tweets before I could
even go in there because I was still
sitting in the in the hospital
responding to people you know before I
could even go in there my community
jumped in and said no no I just got a
tweet I just got an email
I think that there's no excuse to not
try I can't wrap my head around if you
have a community why you wouldn't spend
an hour a day responding and that were
playing for example I just did a Pierce
Morgan show it's coming up we did I did
how was that it was cool yeah you know
in in there I kind of called him out he
was kind of talking go Pierce look at
you I he was asking me about this I said
Pierce look at you you're a big star and
he was really funny he was like say it
again I was like okay you're a big star
and I go but this was a great moment I
hope they don't edit out I'm like but
you don't care about any people watching
your show the only people you're
tweeting with is Seacrest and Oprah and
all the other celebrities and you think
you're so cool how about the actual real
people the bottom line is this I don't
think there's a number too big
if 14,000 people tweet at you and you
respond to 300 that means a whole lot to
those 300 and you systematically fight
against the tide you can't necessarily
win and get to everybody but that effort
is being seen by the world go right now
tonight and look at like 500 or 50 or
100 internet celebrities or real
celebrities and look at their timeline I
will guarantee you that 99% of them are
pushing out [ __ ] and retweeting which is
another thing we did the whole Japan
thing here's another one
if you retweet something that was
awesomely said about you you're [ __ ]
bragging like we might stop you know
I mean it's black I mean why are we not
putting human elements to this stuff
right I mean like it's like it's like
mash you thought that's what it was for
so my point is this my point is if
you're putting in the effort there's
value people are feeling that you would
go look you go look at my screen right
now here's what you're gonna see 90% at
replies and 10% me pushing out stuff
like that's it by my book right you know
what I mean and so I'm not scared to
push you know I don't want to give it
away for free I want to sell stuff I
want people download my app I'm not
letting anybody leave here tonight
unless you show me that you have the app
on your iPhone you know so I'll get
gangsters a lot but you know I I
definitely I definitely feel that people
are just not caring about the end user
enough because we didn't have to let's
call a spade a spade we just lived
through the great Box era the big box
store Walmart Costco right these
companies didn't have to it was about
price it was about convenience social
equity is gonna matter it's happening
every day and it's just very very
obvious to me either I'm gonna be very
right or very wrong and I'm gonna bet
him I think I think it now that I mean I
just when I went to New York for the
holidays
I got snowed in and the way I got out on
virgin was they were following me on
Twitter a direct messages with him I got
them on the phone they got me out on an
early flight then I was in New York and
the guys from the Nick said you know
you're in town because I tweeted every
knick game they said are you coming to
the game I said yeah I'm gonna get some
tickets where they said oh no we got two
tickets for you already come in second
row and you're feeling that now because
you're a brand in the space I think it
trickles down from your mountain right
now you're in a different place than a
lot of people they look at your
following account you've got brand
equity is that the other thing what I
get fascinated about I'm actually not so
fascinated about how you get trade
treated and I doing Kevin than that yeah
actually I actually don't give a [ __ ]
about that I'm curious about when it
trickles down the mountain and we start
treating Sally Arkansas and Timmy Iowa
and Peter LA is that really gonna happen
yes because here's why they're spending
that money to get those people now
they're giving it to newspaper ads
they're giving it to Google so we if you
were running one of the airlines you
would just say forget no more air no
more television commercials they know hi
r100 Oh or they'll cut 25% of the
commercials now you're getting more
interesting listen I love traditional
media I by the way I'm glad I'm glad we
got
I'm a huge TV guy radio print billboard
it doesn't sound like it I'm all-in
here's my problem I don't like the
pricing I don't think the pricing
Darrell writes it again
yeah I mean listen I bought billboards
for my book instead of $16,000 I paid a
thousand how'd you do that
I went gangster nice I negotiated I said
I'll pay you this and they're like all
right I mean you know I mean it's pretty
scary what you can get when you start
asking right so anyway I think that you
have to have a better mix and I think
that if you late and the funniest part
is I'm talking about layering human
beings on top of technology if you look
at Groupon woman wasn't buying their
tech I don't think anybody here can't
you know any developer in this building
right now could have probably replicated
the tech in 48 hours right yeah they
weren't buying the mailing list if
Google wanted the mailing list one
little design change for two weeks on
Google and they could have had that
mailing list every one of the blood the
brand no they wanted the sales people
who had the relationship with every
little sushi restaurant and Chinese
restaurant and liquor store and Pilate
place the human element of Groupon is
dramatically more valuable than you can
imagine social I you know I would look
at it that way yeah you know maybe I
mean if during this cold curve I I think
it is very fascinating by the way I
think this is such a big maturity of the
Internet itself what we're talking about
is not social media we're talking about
the Internet's only 17 years old it's
only been 17 years since AOL spammed all
our mailboxes right and it's maturing
and it's bringing human elements to the
table
here's a little alert we're humans yes
it's how we roll it's what we do it's
who we are and I'm just fascinated by
this tremendously let me ask you a
farmer question yeah
if tomorrow you woke up and well the
Gary Vaynerchuk stuff you've done all
the book yep and all the consulting
let's say well that somehow magically
wrapped itself up I know somebody came
in bought all those asses right now
clean slate there's absolutely nothing
on your punch list the email box is at
zero
yeah I'll bar zero and you've got you
know tons of money in the bank whatever
what what would you do
and a business out you spend time your
family but sure on a view people do that
hard cut and then do something else
would you be a talk-show host would you
want a movie would you would you would
you want to be an athlete what would you
want to be you know I like selling stuff
I'm a retailer right so I probably would
do a retail startup but I would tell you
this and I've said this to a couple of
close friends cuz I think it's so weird
and I'm not sure it's like a normal
thing to think but I always get very
like transparent on your set so even
more so than normal I secretly want to
lose everything you want to lose
everything I secretly want to lose
everything I secretly for a while now
have been interested in the thought of
the internet and alcohol being banned
and what would happen because I'm so
confident in my chops I want to show
everybody that I can go to dead zero and
build it all back up so when you painted
that picture that excited me huh because
I would love to start the happiest I've
been during this whole journey hasn't
been where I am now which is right now
I'm at the height of my popularity and
financials from this whole five year run
since Wine Library TV started my
favorite day was the day I started
whining rbtv because I taped in front of
a camera i sat there and i said
everybody i know is about to think i've
lost my [ __ ] all my employees are gonna
be scared about what i'm about to do it
was scary but not for me right right I
knew exactly what was gonna happen I
hated the articles in O seven in O eight
when I started blowing up people like
Gary could you believe this happened to
you I was like yeah like I knew that I
had the chops I knew I was gonna work
every everybody was scared to just look
into a camera and talk at that time
there was like three shows was you
Zay Zay and then rocket rocket boom it
was like okay well there are three
things for watch on the internet yeah
yeah I just was it you shut you saw say
we saved I so say here's what happened
why Marie calm was rockin I sat closer
than we're sitting right now to my lead
developer it's how I learned all this
it's how I learned about you he's like
check out this guy Anil - I'm like [ __ ]
that guy check out this guy Jayson cocky
[ __ ] him you know like I was like [ __ ]
all these guys waxy or go give a [ __ ]
about because I'm better on these guys
but that was like wait a minute these
guys are onto something right every day
sitting there you know in 2001 when he
started he's like why are you going to
Yahoo check out Google I'm like this is
the dumb
site I've ever seen a blank white page
how are these [ __ ] gonna make money
I'm glad I wasn't making predictions
back then you know uh and I kept looking
and blogging and bloggers and I'm like
[ __ ] I wish I could write I wish I could
write which is so funny about all this
because then I would blog and then when
I saw YouTube super early on I was like
okay this [ __ ] is interesting right
right and so then they came and they're
like obsessed with say every lunch break
I'm sitting there trying to sell wine
and they're like bawling over themselves
and finally finally I hung up one sales
call and I was like I can do that and
they were like no and then I was like
[ __ ] I got to do this yeah so I was like
fine so basically they were so obsessed
with a and you know what it actually was
it was rocket boom signing a deal with
Tebow that tilted me right around that
same day Woods a like a week later I
they said did you hear that rocket boom
signed a deal with Tebow and then at
this time Tebow was like no that was
that was like the iPad and iPhones and
like rolled into one
when Tebow was like that's it I mean I
couldn't you know it was it and so I was
like holy [ __ ]
really and that was it literally I was
like okay one I got approved by
developers wrong but I'm better than
they and two if you can sign a deal with
Tebow this thing is going places and I
sat down I taped that show in February
most six and I just knew and that was my
favorite time so you telling me a day in
the world I would like to even add that
I wish I could race fall my equity
forget about the money I wish nobody
here knew who I was I'd love right now
to start from zero go into some like you
know how comedians go into like bars and
like Tennessee and work on their craft I
kind of feel like that I start up guys I
just gonna go like Sri Lanka right now
and start busy to start like yeah I feel
ready a group on there and see if you
can get a go I'm just soaked Jason I'm
gonna tell you one thing right now I so
don't care about stuff for money
everybody knows I want to buy the Jets
right but I can say it here I'm gonna
break more news for you I really don't
care if I buy the Jets or not I'm
obsessed with the process yes
I'm obsessed with the process the grind
I like to see am i as good as you
because you sold you know weblog thing I
want to see like I see [ __ ] Andrew
Mason with move I'm like [ __ ] you know
like [ __ ] I you know it motivates me I'm
hungry but what I know is that I'm not
the kind of guy that's gonna build those
kind of
I'm the marathon runner I know that
everybody's gonna wake up in 35 years
and be like [ __ ] he got some things
right he and so that's what I and when I
write these books I'm in the business of
being right about three years from now
and crush it
I went bonkers on tumblr right yeah I
got so many emails in 2009 why do you
like Tom like tumblr stupid like posters
he's gonna kill tumblr like all this
[ __ ] that's homeless and load and it's I
mean it's the Sun it's number three I
mean if you talk to any normal 15 16 17
year old in America today they're on
tumblr they're growing by a quarter of a
billion page views a week it's it's one
and I'm starting to get emails from
people like saying how did you know that
why do you think that you're now seeing
a lot of bullish stuff on video right
yep I get a compliment from you in there
that means a lot to me because you're
not a clown your executor you build
businesses that was because I did it and
making this pivot to mobile and doing a
newsletter people gonna be like holy
[ __ ] the freemium mobile thing and so
you kind of keep trying to show your
chops I'm in the business of showing my
chops and executing and that's what I'd
like to leave as a legacy because legacy
is all I care about
Wow Gary Vaynerchuk another amazing
episode let's hear for Gary thank you
well done well done and thanks to our
sponsors of course strata and
GoToWebinar and thanks to Squarespace
for hosting a bunch of my women company
you know Anthony he is one of the best
entrepreneurs in the whole game and
nobody knows him because he's not a self
promoter he's not like us no he's
nothing I put my head down head down
behind the scenes broker guy built a
business right when everybody was giving
away platform for free he's like why
here's how I'm gonna do it yeah I mean
you know that conversation needs to be I
mean look look Apple is about to become
evil to everybody right like people to
start realizing it's about closed and
making money and all this stuff can be a
very fascinating space in 24 months I
can't wait to come back and talk about
those things awesome so thank you to
Squarespace blah blah blah blah blah and
watch it yeah oh hey before we close
what eight what do you think of Kevin
situation I guess I dig yeah dig and
just kick a little bit in the last six
months but now he's coming back he's got
a new startup suppose so here's my
thought on this what are you thinking
entrepreneur and like what he's going
through so here's my thought on this and
you know Kevin it lets say call during
this interview is a friend of mine I uh
I kind of equated a little bit to Wine
Library believe it or not in some ways
for me like in the wine world
everybody's so happy that I got
distracted by social and like kind of
left right because like everybody's like
oh like we were gonna be it right you
know I know Kevin is such an
entrepreneur right like I don't want to
talk for him but when you start losing
passion in something it's not going to
be successful and I actually think Diggs
decline alongside Kevin's passion for it
proves his skill more than anything else
right you know if you really dissect it
properly and of course I come from a
clouded lens he is somebody I feel
emotional about right but I think it's
fascinating to watch like like
everything I've become less passionate
about has not done as well and you know
I mean the second I turned off crush it
the first time around it's Amazon ranked
did not do as well and so I think here's
a very interesting time for Kevin's
career and it's gonna be interesting for
a lot of us you know second acts third
second acts third acts I mean this is
also new
right we're also new we're all new to
the game like by the way it's why I
think Jeff here's a bomb
I think Jeff Bezos is a better
entrepreneur than Steve Jobs I think
Bezos better because for me he's
continued to innovate so much out of his
circle it's not just Amazon it's not
just Kindle it's you know it's II too
easy
it's the services which is by the way
soon we're gonna have conversations that
if Amazon services go down our economy's
in trouble like it's so important and
have a Mechanical Turk and how about
buying woot and do the deal is to have a
buying Zappos in this book I say the
data Thank You economy was born was when
Amazon bought Zappos cuz they didn't
buying four more shoes they bought up
for culture and understanding where this
world going and so you know I think
Kevin his jury is still out he did
something he did something very special
he's one of the faces of the world that
we all know yeah my most happy day in
2006 doing while every TV is when Wine
Library TV made the front page of Digg I
know what happened was it was what he
lived for and I'm very curious about
what he's gonna do next and he doesn't
get credit for f3 which is doing
tremendous yeah III think he's I know
him extremely well I've been in a lot of
entrepreneurial jam sessions where
people show their job
I have a very good feeling he'll be
successful don't forget he was a fast
follower to Twitter with pounce write
and pounce did a lot of things that
Twitter just implemented with no hasn't
done right and his big downfall there
was a lot of the down poll I see myself
and you probably feel it too when you're
a hardcore entrepreneur you try to do
too much [ __ ] yeah the ad D gets you it
gets you sometimes it gets you all right
guys we'll see you next time on the
space